hi I'm Travis Fillmore and this is Paula
Patton hello I'm Toby Kebbell and I'm
Rob Kazinsky and we're doing in Google
or a correct or complete autocomplete
thing the first one we are all too real
oh we aren t that'll be on there so our
aux note reels give me the first one
alright real do you reckon anymore so oh
no no no our orcs real yeah yeah you
told you I could've comprehend did
anyone ask if they're real yeah well you
know one of them's running for the
nominee for the Republican Party so that
I understand the confusion where the
Trump means fart in English yeah that
doesn't always know one hotel is Trump
Towers are copyrighted
oh that's a good question good question
actually Tolkien wasn't into copyright
incident a week I don't know I don't
know our orcs L is black white is our
fish dry it's like no absolutely not
elves in fact the antithesis thereof and
they'll that works can all speak English
yes oh yeah can you speak Spanish if you
learn it yes yeah then also speak
English channels travel in daylight yes
even I'm paralyzed can't orcs marry in
skyrim i never played an orc in scar
room I also never bother to get mad I
did marry someone once and then kill
them just because I'm weird
yeah cannot be priests Wow
load of Warcraft yeah and they play that
class and no they can't turn aux yeux
swords yeah be like using little
miniature fault
yeah oh there's more orcs be good yes
and half Oryx take human features what
do you think yes can't orcs and humans
meet we hope so yeah oh yes have babies
definitely can't orcs breed with elves
now that my goggles aha eyes wrong with
you who giggled that question that's
just silly
how does rule craft affect the brain by
being lights and sound yeah how does
Warcraft work you pay money someone
gives you game
how does Warcraft make money by charging
you extortion amount
good tipper you see what they're gonna
say about you
mmm is Travis femme all Irish yeah close
enough good okay
his job is the mall I'm gonna get her
well they throw nice um depends on the
day
all right there's something between us
it's called chemistry miss Travis film
all married I was wondering about that
one students like really certain like
that with me at the bar next question is
Johnston mall here real Vikings you were
extension real men wear extensions does
world of warcraft have a good story yes
it does and that's why we're able to
make a good movie about it it does world
of warcraft have viruses I mean it has
bugs but no does world of warcraft have
moisture it does have voice chat in the
game but not good does world of warcraft
event no it's better than never ending
story would you hit dead for two hours
on this leading total classic World of
Warcraft charge monthly yes it does what
is it a couple of dollars a 15 bucks 15
bucks a month
yeah is Paula Patton and Antoine ah
related you'd think with the name but no
we're not just Paula Patton Canadian
indeed no I'm not Canadian either is
Paula Patton hot yeah it's Paula Patton
baggage claim yes I'm in baggage claim
she's fantastic in that movie you you've
pledged that much yeah it's fantastic
can't imagine you I see that if you're
in it I'm watching it
ah yes Paula Patton related to V ah rock
yes
you see no absol walk hard no I'm I'm
not related to them to the rock you're
not no Paula Patton's not related to the
rock
you are one mode its Warcraft really
addictive yeah sorry Mike yeah is walk
rough really that good yeah is Warcraft
really free is it free cos your soul
I'll give you $100 if you can guess this
next one is raw Kraft really a great
movie made by Duncan Joan and the answer
is yes no it's fun thank you for
watching and don't take everything we
said you know as the truth what you like
being these to be back well someone
Google that